et nous sommes avec thomas porte porte
parole du mouvement générations et
stéphane rozès politologue président de
cap
bonsoir messieurs et merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france
est ce que c'est une réécriture de
façade stéphane rozès vous partagez elle
est critique il ya des manifestants
comment le texte a évolué depuis son
examen à l'assemblée nationale c'était
des arts au clairement notamment
l'article 24 vous l'avez mentionné une
dispositions liberticides dans la mesure
où au fond les termes utilisés étaient
suffisamment floue au départ pour que ça
représente une limitation claire du
travail des journalistes ou de ceux qui
auraient pu filmer alors on va boire la
formulation définitive le gouvernement a
choisi une navette accélérée a bien vu
qu'il y avait des oppositions dans le
pays
ces oppositions perdu sur le fond donc
je pense qu'il ya deux types de
discussions entre nous la question du
fond et donc on parle là et puis de
façon générale
au fond ce que signifie un 7/10 cette
loi sécurité globale est ce que ça
signifie aussi sur l'évolution des
libertés publiques et du rapport de
l'opinion à ces questions là qui de mon
point de vue d'analystes se sont
dégradées avec une sorte du fait de la
peur de forme de consentement à des
shows si autrefois n'auraient pas été
acceptée alors controversé article 24 a
donc été réécrit et remplacé en
commission au sénat par un délit de
provocation à l'identification
est-ce que c'est donc là la fin de la
polémique thomas porte non je crois que
c'est pas c'était pas une polémique
c'était une bataille sur le fond d'une
loi qui était liberticide et qu'on
rejette depuis le début parce
qu'effectivement où vous l'avez dit
l'article 24 cristallisé beaucoup de
colère et d'impact médiatique autour de
lui mais on rejette le projet de loi sur
le fond parce qu'on a aussi un transfert
des missions de sécurité qui appartenait
aujourd'hui au service public vers une
privatisation de la justice et des mains
du maintien de l'ordre
on a le recours à l'usagé des drones on
alors au courant on pourra récupérer les
images de vidéosurveillance et des
caméras des forces de police pour faire
des opérations de communication en
direct
donc il ya tout un champ de cette loi
qui remet en cause les libertés
individuelles dans ce pays
et effectivement je partage qui vient
d'être dit c'est que le gouvernement il
a une stratégie celle d'aller vite parce
qu à une contestation qui s'enracine
dans le pays et malgré tout ce qu'on a
dit il continue iard démobilisation il
n'aura une mardi devant le sénat
à 16 heures ou au moment où le texte
sera discuté et il ya quelque part des
fois une acceptation populaire face à un
effet de sidération dans une période
pandémique ou c'est très difficile de se
mobiliser
et pourtant malgré ce passage en force
on avait tous les arguments qu'on nous a
amenés aujourd'hui on a des gens qui
contient sont mobilisés partout dans le
pays pour dire qu'ils ne veulent pas de
cette loi qui ne veulent pas d'avoir une
atteinte à leur liberté
et aujourd'hui ce processus sécuritaire
dans lequel s'enferre de l'état est
extrêmement préoccupant alors vous
évoquez les usages des drones on évoque
un cadre légal désormais plus sécurisé
justement pour cet usage des drôles de
leur image et celle des caméras piétons
à des forces de l'ordre quel est votre
regard là-dessus stéphane rozès les
difficultés qu'on a c'est que ya
effectivement des clarifications qu'ils
peuvent aller dans le bon sens par
rapport à l'article 24 de la provocation
mais ensuite ça va être caisse comment
définir comment définir les déments de
provocation est ce qu'au fond la menace
de recours judiciaire ne va pas au fond
et limiter la liberté d'expression
les français globalement soutiennent des
forces de l'ordre elles ont été
utilisées ces dernières années comme
variable de de consentement dans la
contradiction entre ce que ressentent
les français et des politiques qui ont
été menées de sorte que les forces de
ordre ont été surutilisés pour s'occuper
de la question du maintien de l'ordre ce
qui a fait une dépendance du coût du
sommet de l'état à l'égard de la dette
qu'il doit aux forces de l'ordre pour
maintenir des éléments d'ordre public et
les policiers ont pu être à juste titre
dans certains cas déstabilisé par le
fait qu' ils finissent subir les
éléments d'identification enhco la
question de fond c'est la question de
l'encadrement par les mollahs schori
spread ans alors il va y avoir des
recours pour s'assurer que des choses ne
soient pas liberticide sur la question
des drones
defacto les techniques ça toujours été
comme ça des techniques précède les
encadrements donc les drones ici et
ailleurs sont de plus en plus utilisés
là aussi alors je suis pas un
spécialiste en analyse question moi je
suis mes dadas question de la garantie
des libertés publiques est vraiment
quelque chose est vraiment quelque chose
de décisif horn a le sentiment que en
france et dans d'autres pays d'ailleurs
effectivement l'état de crise sanitaire
les crises sociales
tous ces éléments de dispositifs font
que effectivement il ya une pression
forte sur les libertés publiques et que
les français comme dans d'autres pays un
tiers peuvent au fond consentir à des
dispositions qui peuvent avoir des
effets pervers parce qu'au fond tout
dépendra du type d'utilisation
garate république à ne pas du maintien
de leurs
andré donc là il ya une brèche il ya une
brèche s'est ouverte cette proposition
de loi sécurité globale elle comporte
aussi des articles concernant les
polices municipales et la sécurité
privée vous en parler thomas porte après
le passage du texte en commission des
lois au sénat les futures compétences
des polices municipales apparaissent
elles limitées - sous traitance
finalement aussi pour la sécurité privée
est-ce que ce qu'elle vous semble
suffisant thomas porte ou est-ce que ça
à pêche encore dont évidemment ça va pas
assez loin puisque on sera bien content
qu'aujourd'hui la police municipale elle
est utilisée comme recours au maintien
de l'ordre qui doit être la
responsabilité de l'état et par le fait
qu'il y ait des baisses de dotations et
des casses dans le service pack de la
police et des réductions de postes on a
un recours à une police municipale qui
n'est pas fort mais qui n'est pas apte à
mener des opérations de maintien de
l'ordre
donc il ya des choses qui sont
extrêmement dangereuses et pour revenir
sur ce que vous avez dit sur les grandes
vous parlez d'encadrement mais on a
quand même eu un exemple avec le préfet
de police de paris qui a été rappelé
plusieurs fois à l'ordre pour usage de
drogues que c'était interdit qui trompe
pas c'est la loi qui a continué à
utiliser ces drones donc il ya une
véritable inquiétude là dessus hier je
rappelle les césars il ya une saynète
une réalisatrice qui a dit la liberté
dont 22 dérobé sous nos pieds c'est un
peu ce qui se passe aujourd'hui on a on
a un recours massif à des systèmes de
surveillance du maintien de l'ordre de
plus en plus violents et la seule
réponse qui est apporté par l'état c'est
une réponse sécuritaire et on voit bien
que depuis des mois c'est la question
sociale qui est au coeur des
préoccupations des français est la seule
réponse aujourd'hui de l'état c'est pour
ça qu'elle est aussi que emmanuel macron
et son ministre gérald darmanin l'âge de
plus en plus de choses aux syndicats
policiers
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la contestation et
la colère sociale est tellement
importante que la seule la répression
est à même de la juguler alors qu'on
attend d'autres réponses et comment est
ce que vous voyez dans la suite de la
mobilisation contre le texte et on
importe vous vous rappeliez cette
mobilisation mardi prochain alors que
débutera au sénat en séance plénière à
l'examen de cette proposition de loi
sécurité globale je crois que j'espère
qu'ils auront le plus de monde possible
évidemment devant le sénat pour
manifester notre opposition à ce projet
de loi dont on n'entend rien je le
rappelle le retrait total et intégrale
du texte
les suites c'est le collectif qui a en
charge des mobilisations qui valait
décidé il ya eu des dates à l'agenda
parlée par les mois passaient tous les
samedis je crois qu'il va y avoir
d'autres mobilisations qui vont
continuer y aura après des sûrement des
recours juridiques pour contester cette
loi là mais on ne peut pas se satisfaire
d'une telle loi en plus dans un
calendrier
quand même législatif qui est
extrêmement serré puisqu'il a été
rappelé une espèce de navettes
parlementaires qui est ultraserré qui
permet pas de débat et je crois qu'une
loi aussi importante qui remet en cause
tant de liberté mérite un véritable
débat républicaine on parle pas
aujourd'hui du de ne remettre à plat la
fonction du maintien de l'ordre en
gérald darmanin
je termine là dessus a convoqué le
bourreau de la sécurité mais dans ce
cadre là il fait parler des policiers
des experts de sécurité il associe pas
les citoyens les associations qui
oeuvrent dans les quartiers populaires
alors qu'on nous parle à longueur de
journée à juste titre de recréer des
liens entre la police et la population
est on en train ne pas donner la parole
aux gens qui sont sur le terrain donc
c'est extrêmement problématique un
dernier mot avec vous un stéphane rozès
est-ce que vous pensez que la
mobilisation peut conduire on peut aller
jusqu'aux peut conduire au retrait tout
simplement de ce texte de loi
c'était un peu le monde clos de départ
c'est à dire que il ya eu des des
violences importantes dont les forces de
l'ordre ont été des victimes et dont des
manifestants ont également été les
victimes et nous sommes dans un moment
où l'opinion publique préfère un ordre
fusse-t-il injustes ou des ordres
voilà d'un point de vue anthropologique
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans les
rangs fermement des sociétés donc il est
du ressort des républicains et de l'état
de droit de trouver des bons
s'équilibrent entre le fait
qu'effectivement des forces de l'ordre
soient protégés mais que le droit de
manifester que les manifestants
soit protégé il n'est pas normal que des
manifestants au moment où ils vont dans
des manifestations puisse redouter
quelque chose pour leur intégrité
physique
donc la réponse à votre question ne
dépend pas seulement des mobilisations
pas ça ne dépend pas seulement des lois
ou pas ça dépend aussi du fait que les
gouvernants soient indexés sur la
souveraineté populaire et que les
politiques menées ou sommet de l'état
correspondent à la situation de la
nation et tant qu'il n'y aura pas de
cohérence entre nos institutions les
politiques menées et ce qu'est notre
nation ce que son ce qui est à la fois
son imaginaire national mais aussi ses
interrogations ses tensions sociales
certains cas ces contradictions sociales
alors il y aura de plus en plus de
recours ou question d'un retrait qui
sont des questions de court terme alors
que ce n'est que l'effet de mécanismes
de moyen et de long terme qui ne peut
être approprié par nos politiques sinon
nous irons de plus en plus vers des
sociétés faisant prévaloir les libertés
collectives c'est-à-dire le commun sur
les libertés individuelles et le respect
démocratique et on aura l'occasion de
revenir sur ce texte de loi sécurité
globale merci à tous les deux messieurs
stéphane rozès politologue président de
cap et on m'apporte porte-parole
génération mercière et à bientôt sur rt
france